[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue merci
d'être avec nous en ce vendredi pour la
dernière émission de la semaine en
compagnie de rachel vinasse mon soir
vous êtes journaliste vous collaborez à
l'express à mariana lci aussi on vous
voit notamment chez david pujadas
et puis ferghana diaries est là aussi
bonsoir faire grimper ce soir vous êtes
analyste en politiques publiques à
l'iref qui est un think tank libéral
vous êtes aussi le délégué général de
l'académie des sciences humaines on
savait que les français ou en tout cas
une partie d'entre eux pouvaient être
réticents à se faire vacciner mais on a
découvert que les soignants les
infirmières les médecins même parfois ne
sont pas complètement étranger à ces
réticences qu'il ne font pas
nécessairement exception écoutez ce
qu'en disait hier le ministre de la
santé olivier ans lors de la conférence
de presse désormais traditionnel du
jeudi soir
en pratique ce sont 40 % des soignants
en ehpad et 30% des soignants sur
l'ensemble du système de santé qui sont
vaccinées
clairement ça ne suffit pourtant pas
nous disposons je le rappel de vaccin
efficace
à commencer par le vaccin astrazeneca je
vous le dis en franchise quand on est
soignants il est de notre responsabilité
de se protéger soi-même et d'éviter
d'exposer ce dont on prend soin au
risque d'un virus qui peut les percuter
durement
alors le ministre fait attention aux
jouets des mots il parle poliment
certains spécialistes sont plus directs
comme le professeur françois chast c'est
l'un des pontes de l'assistance
publique-hôpitaux de paris voilà ce
qu'ils disaient à nos confrères de
france inter
on a vacciné 80% des personnes hébergées
dans les ehpad et on note que 30 à 40%
des personnels acceptent de se faire
vacciner
c'est scandaleux ce n'est pas normal
alors que se passe-t-il pourquoi ces
réticences avant d'en débattre je vous
propose d'écouter le témoignage de
noémie bannalec infirmières et
présidente du collectif intérieur change
aujourd'hui on n'est pas contre ce
vaccin
le lait les soignants ont la liberté de
choisir s'ils se font vacciner ou non je
pense que les libertés des soignants
comme de la population en général est
assez affecté depuis un an pour
qu'aujourd'hui on nous laisse le choix
de savoir ce qu'on fait l'astra
zehnacker le voit très bien dans tous
mes collègues sur le territoire en étant
présent du collectif et intérieurs ans
je le vois bien tous ceux qui se sont
fait vacciner ont des effets secondaires
majeurs âgés mais là c'est une petite
bombe cette déclaration parce que on va
parler de mon cas personnel qui
n'intéresse personne mais tant pis moi
je suis plutôt favorable à l'idée de me
faire vacciner quand mon tour viendra
mais en même temps si je vois une
infirmière qui dit il ya des effets
secondaires majeurs à au vaccin
astrazeneca
j'avoue que ça refroidit un peu mon
enthousiasme peut-être le seul mais je
suis pas certain non non je ne pense pas
non plus on ne s'y attendait pas vous
l'avais dit dans l'introduction on
imaginer en effet que la crainte
deviendraient des des français dans leur
globalité mais on imaginait moins que
ces réticences puissent venir du corps
médical lui même corps médical qui est
pourtant habitué normalement à certaines
obligations qui est censé faire passer
ses droits individuels puisque c'est ça
qui a été évoqué après l'intérêt
collectif
d'ailleurs ces obligations elles
existent elles existent alors quand vous
soyez à l'hôpital vous devez être
vaccinés contre l'hépatite b pas mais
avant même c'est une obligation avant
même de démarrer les études enfin à
partir de membres vous allez démarrer
pour être plus précise vous êtes
obligatoirement vous devez être vaccinés
contre l'hépatite b et le tétanos et
c'est donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
existe déjà
c'est quelque chose que connaissent les
soignants à partir du moment où
justement ils veulent exercer cette
profession parce que parce qu'ils ont
une fonction particulière parce que il
apparaît aujourd'hui comme un scandale
et à juste titre que le coc vite
devienne une maladie nosocomiale
je serai la trappe à l'hôpital on
l'attend à peine on arrive à l'hôpital
pour une autre maladie et on en ressort
avec le collier et parfois même on en
mer oui enfin le meilleur décor
aujourd'hui on sait que environ si je me
trompe à 184 personnes sont mortes
ducobu après l'avoir attrapé après avoir
été infectés à l'hôpital donc donc c'est
un sujet majeur et il est surprenant que
certains soignants décide comme ça de
faire passer encore une fois leurs choix
personnels avant leurs fonctions un
intérêt l'intérêt collectif
parce que la solution du coup c'est de
rendre obligatoire ce
vaccin astrazeneca pour l'instant c'est
celui qui est le plus facile à trouver
un grande partie des doses qui sont
disponibles et qui ne servent pas est ce
que est ce que la contrainte une bonne
solution ferghana ziari alors une
obligation oui une coercition non je
m'explique sur cette histoire déjà pour
revenir sur ce cas dit rachel juste fait
d'accord je suis scandalisée de voir que
le corps médical fasse preuve d'autant
de réticences d'autant plus que ça fait
bientôt un an que le personnel soignant
ont fait du lobbying auprès du
gouvernement pour tous tous confinés
donc avec un autoritarisme décomplexée
on nous demande des efforts vont très
bien a admis ton pourquoi pas mais la
moindre des choses c'est que le
personnel soignant
quand bien même il fait un travail
remarquable sur le terrain est bien doit
lui aussi participer à cet effort
collectif qui consiste à ne pas imposer
une externalité négative au patient qui
est justement rentrer dans ces
établissements et peuvent se faire
contaminer donc la réticence du
personnel soignant qui censée montrer
l'exemple et tolérables et moi même
j'avoue que lorsque j'ai vu ces chiffres
tombent et gd comme dans un état j'étais
assez énervé et c'est en colère contre
pour ne rien vous cacher je les rappelle
ces chiffres et après je vous passe la
parole 30% des soignants voilà sont
vaccinés et 40% des soignants en ehpad
alors qu'a priori c'est là que le risque
est le plus grand même s'il ya de plus
en plus de pensionnaires qui sont eux
même vacciné ça qui est vraiment assez
incroyable harmattan contrainte alors je
moi je suis assez mal à l'aise toujours
à l'idée d'envoyer des policiers
mettre des amendes à ceux qui ne se
seraient pas vaccinés en revanche en
revanche comment ya rien n'empêche la
liberté individuelle n'empêche pas à
l'exercice d'une saine pression sociale
qui consisterait tout simplement à
reconnaître aux établissements la
liberté de conditionner l'emploi du
personnel soignant à une obligation
vaccinale en disant tout simplement et
bien en effet vous êtes libre de refuser
de vous faire vacciner
en revanche vous n'êtes pas libre de
faire courir un risque aux patientes
dans les établissements donc vous êtes
libre de vous faire virer en cas de
refus donc c'est tout simplement une une
application de la liberté contractuelle
qui permettrait aux employés et aux
employeurs pardon de
de ces personnels soignants et vient de
conditionner tout simplement le maintien
de leur emploi dans un établissement à
une obligation vaccinale c'est la
moindre des choses ça vaut aussi je
crois que ça vaut aussi pour les
entreprises c'est à dire que lorsque se
posera la question est bien d'aider des
règles à adopter quand les vaccins
seront suffisamment abondante et bien je
pense qu'il faudra aussi reconnaître aux
établissements privés aux entreprises la
possibilité bien de contractualiser tout
simplement une obligation vaccinale avec
leurs employés à charge pour
pour chacun d'entre nous ensuite daksi
d'accepter ou non cette obligation
vaccinale mais en tout cas en étant
préparé à en subir les conséquences
sociales ce qui ne signifie pas la
prison je ne suis pas pour mettre les
gens en prison où nous mettre leur
mettre une amende mais ce qui peut
impliquer une forme d'ostracisation de
ceux qui refuseraient tout simplement
est bien de se vacciner et de protéger
les autres tout simplement d'accord avec
cette procédure
oui même si j'observe une certaine
pudeur dans le langage il s'agit quand
même à la fin d'une contrainte parce que
si vous expliquer un salarié qui ne
pourra pas travailler
je suis d'accord avec vous sur le fond
entièrement cessé je joue un peu sur ma
faim en montrant ce n'est pas le même
type mais l'aurait questionner le
résultat le résultat est le même si on
vous explique que vous ne pourrez pas
travailler si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
ce qui pour moi est une bonne chose en
tout cas dans le cadre de l'hôpital il
n'y a même pas de deux voilà il faut pas
pinailler là dessus à la fin bien sûr
que vous vacciner vous n'avez pas
d'autre choix si vous voulez travailler
et le travail du texte dire que gagne on
peut imaginer des établissements où les
employés sont plutôt jeunes bien
portants ou personne de retard
oui à l'hôpital où il répétait
effectivement c'est une forme
d'obligations alors l'obligation pour
moi quand même le mot a un sens parce
que dans l'idée d' obligations et l'idée
quand même d'une norme consenti alors
que l'idée de contraintes il ya
davantage aidés de pression extérieure
toujours est il que derrière on ne
sacralise pas on refuse de sacraliser
l'individualisme au nom dans l'intérêt
collectif
la conclusion est forcément la même et
tant mieux et en plus je pense qu'on a
tout intérêt à le faire si on est
simplement un peu malin même même un peu
froide un peu machiavélique si je puis
dire c'est que si on ne le fait pas les
hôpitaux les soignants s'exposent à des
poursuites à des poursuites judiciaires
on peut aisément croire qu' un certain
nombre de français va souhaiter
poursuivre des soignants que j'aurais
refusé justement de se faire vacciner et
dont les proches justement aura été
malade ou rhéaume auraient perdu la vie
on parle quand même je crois de plus de
quarante quatre mille personnes qui ont
été tuées ont attrapé le coc vide à
l'hôpital la moitié de patients la
moitié des soignants au moins plus de
180 ont perdu la vie la question se pose
aussi ses selles c'est celle des
poursuites judiciaires et des affaires
qui vont qui vont s'ouvrir les
contraintes les salariés ça va pas être
simple parce que vous savez que
l'essentiel du système hospitalier en
france
ces systèmes publics et donc c'est la
fonction publique hospitalière avec des
statuts d'une rigidité qui n'a rien à
envier à celle de les chrétiens d âge
uqtr extrêmement puissant donc d'ici à
ce que d'ici à ce que les directions
d'hôpitaux aux prendre des sanctions
contre les soignants à mon avis il va se
passer un petit peu de temps je vous
livre le point de vue de nos chers
internautes faut-il rendre obligatoire
la vaccination
contre le cobp et 19 pour les soignants
bas vous répondez oui à 58% alors c'est
intéressant parce que on vous pose la
question dans tous les sens avec nous on
est pour la démocratie participative
comme ségolène royal donc on vous pose
la question aussi sur youtube ou là vous
répondez non à 75% basse et tous sont
les gens qui sont en train de suivre en
direct et qui réagit c'est une très
bonne chose
quelques réactions celle de vole pas eu
sur lefigaro.fr
il paraît que pour le simple vaccin de
la grippe saisonnière beaucoup refusent
déjà babineau qui considère que la
liberté vaccinale des soignants
s'accompagne d'un devoir de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des patients à
risque
chardon bleu nous fait remarquer que les
militaires eux sont bien vacciné
obligatoirement sylvie sur youtube est
une soignante et qui témoigne j'ai été
malade du coc vide en mars 2020 j'ai
fait ma sérologie et j'ai encore onze
mois après des anticorps et on va
m'obliger à me faire vacciner point
d'interrogation c'est la création
suffira et puis à pauline sur youtube
qui nous dit
les soignants ne sont pas des personnes
différentes des autres français ils ont
le droit de refuser comme le reste de la
population
parce que c'est vrai que dans votre
position à l'un et à l'autre il ya le
sous-entendu ou le présupposé plutôt que
ces vaccins ne sont pas dangereux et que
donc à un refus relève plus de la
mauvaise volonté que d'une que d'une
inquiétude légitime
on est d'accord c'est pas une question
de dia qu'il n'y a pas de risque le
risque zéro n'existe pas c'est une
chienne de balance bénéfice risque
aujourd'hui il ya un consensus une
littérature scientifique qui semble
indiquer que la balance bénéfices
risques est en faveur de la vaccination
bon dans ces cas là moi il me semble
légitime que l'établissement qu'ils le
veulent et bien impose cette obligation
vaccinale au nom de cette balance
bénéfice risque
maintenant ceux qui ne veulent
absolument pas se faire vacciner
- quoique je suis libéral dont je ne
compte rien à personne
en revanche ce que je dis à ces gens
savent alors se trouver un autre métier
parce que ce n'est pas possible de se
soustraire à ses obligations là quand on
est à
quand on occupe des fonctions aussi
sensible et puissant c'est oui tout à
fait et puis c'est d'autant plus
surprenant de la part de personnes qu'on
a applaudi quand même qu'on a soutenu
qu'on a compris dans les risques qu'ils
encourent et avec tout c'est toute cette
solidarité qui s'est mis en place dans
les supermarchés et ses terrasses et
celle de solidarité pour justement les
soutenir les accompagner dans cette
période qui est compliquée et de voir
cette espèce d'individualisme exacerbé
s'exprimer aujourd'hui alors certes avec
difficulté on sait qui parle pas
totalement de manière libre 1 et ça peut
se comprendre mais c'est dommage
aujourd'hui qui se présenter sous un
jour comme si comme si le lien avec des
cartes étaient rompues c'est un peu
c'est un petit peu compliqué à
appréhender à comprendre
vous pensez faire un achat direct ça
peut faire changer le regard des
français sur effectivement ce qu'on
applaudissait tous les soirs à 20h
ceux qui étaient nos héros pendant le
premier confinement c'est possible en
même temps que les français sont
tellement authier vaccins dans leur
grande majorité il est possible que
c'est plus mitigé aujourd'hui
oui c'est plus mitigé grâce au marketing
de la rareté du gouvernement mais il
n'empêche que moi fin ici ont comparé
l'attitude des français vis-à-vis de la
science trop aujourd'hui il ya quelques
décennies est quand même un changement
spectaculaire c'est à dire que nous
sommes quand même face à une technologie
arn et qui a été mise au point en moins
d'un an qui a été industrialisée hyper
rapidement qui est une prouesse
technologique au sens vraiment premier
du terme
la première chose que nous devons nous
devrions faire c'est nous réjouir de
cette technologie qui est survenu
finalement un an après l'éclatement
cette pandémie et nous sommes tous en
train de faire nous nos enfants gâtés
alors même que
sont pour la plupart je suis désolé il
ya quand même on devrait féliciter ce et
célébrer l'arrivée de tous ces vaccins
qui arrive en moins d'un an sur le
marché - jour ça extraordinaire ça ne va
absolument falloir nous dire le soir et
à votre fenêtre et quand mais
aujourd'hui je constate que là là là là
tu m'appelles la technoscience de
manière un peu péjorative maintenant ne
fait plus rêver parce que effectivement
on a rompu le lien avec des cartons
n'auront plus le lien avec l'homme
maître et possesseur de la nature on se
méfie aujourd'hui de l'homme prométhéen
et tout ceci est fait ici blanc tel état
que des vents et des méfiances pourquoi
pas que des gens et des craintes et tout
à fait c'est ça peut être aussi tout à
fait légitime crois qu'il faut faire
attention déjà d'une part les anti
vaccins pur et dur en france sont pas
aussi important que ce qu'on pensait je
crois que l'une des dernières études
montrent que seuls 3%
grosso modo des français sont réellement
anti vaccins certains veulent attendre
certains vont dire que ce n'est pas le
moment et c'est une chose mais les purs
anti vaccins dits complotistes c'est une
chose ensuite coder des français se
posent des questions et des doutes enfin
on a eu quelques affaires quand même
sanitaire pas très joli je crois que
c'est important aussi d'entendre cette
parole et je parle comme le jardin très
progressiste créé de ne pas de ne pas en
face soit les enfants utilisés soit leur
expliquer qu'ils n'ont rien compris les
doutes c'est sans vouloir être rassuré
sur un produit nouveau qui arrive sur le
marché
pourquoi pas on peut pas se faire non
plus l'économie d'explication sous
prétexte que ces gens-là appartiendrait
à un courant régressif
en tout cas sans doute que il ya un
vaccin qui a été efficace c'est celui
qui a été injecté à la population
française par jacques chirac dans la
constitution ça s'appelait le principe
de précaution est de toute évidence il
joue à fond sur ce sur ce sujet en tout
cas au niveau des soignants on change de
sujet
si vous le voulez bien pour parler d'un
sondage étonnant peut-être inquiétant
vous allez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez
il a été réalisé auprès d'un échantillon
de lycéens donc des adolescents par
l'institut ifop pour la licra et son
magazine de droit de vivre et ce qui
nous apprend c'est que les lycéens sont
en rupture avec ce qui est sans doute
l'opinion dominante en france qui est en
faveur d'une laïcité d'une neutralité en
tout cas d'une forme de réserves de
l'espace public par rapport aux
religions
le premier enseignement de ce sondage
c'est que un peu plus de la moitié des
lycéens 50 2 % sont favorables à léo
aussi religieux à la liberté d'exhiber
des signes religieux dans les lycées
vous savez que c'est aujourd'hui
interdit par la loi
ce qui est intéressant c'est que donc
c'est à peu près moitié moitié alors que
dans l'ensemble de la population
française on est plutôt dans 75% opposé
il ya donc une évolution est évidemment
on va en parler puis l'autre
enseignement de ce sondage c'est que les
lycéens musulmans sont très clairement
en rupture avec le reste de leurs
camarades y compris les catholiques qui
sont très peu nombreux à mettre en avant
des revendications de type expression
religieuse ou communautaire c'est ainsi
que les
étudiant pardon les lycéens musulmans à
76 % sont favorables à l'autorisation de
portait un burqini alors que on est à 38
% donc entre deux fois moins chez
l'ensemble des lycéens de la même façon
les lycéens musulmans sont très
favorables à des horaires séparés pour
la piscine 80% tout ça est assez
spectaculaire est ce que c'est
inquiétant ferghana ziari est-ce que ce
combat de la laïcité il est un peu
perdue selon vous auprès des jeunes
alors rien n'est jamais perdu selon moi
ceci dit effectivement il est tendance
inquiétante qui vont au delà de la
laïcité moi je ne suis pas certain
qu'ils aient failli réduire cette
question à la le principe de laïcité en
tant que tel qui n'est qu'un principe
constitucion de neutralité religieuse
mais qui ne dit absolument rien de la
tolérance qui prévaut au sein d'une
société
un exemple très simple l'aller le
royaume uni n'est pas un état laïque au
sens français du terme puisque le chef
de l'état est aussi le chef de l'église
mais pourtant c'est un pays qui offre
quand même un niveau de liberté de
conscience et d'expression assez élevé
or vous avez évoqué pas mal de chiffres
vous auriez pu aussi noter que moi je
suis là frappé c'est que majorité une
courte majorité d'étudiants n'était pas
favorable à la critique des religions
chez les musulmans ça monte jusqu'à
soixante dix huit pour cent
soixante-deux pour cent de lycéens
seulement veulent obliger les
institutions religieuses à reconnaître
le droit à l'apostasié le droit de
changer de religion non je préfère qu'il
y ait 100 perd 100 % de gens qui
connaissent ce droit donc effectivement
tout ceci est un peu inquiétant est la
question de la rupture des musulmans
avec ses valeurs dites libérales est
tout aussi inquiétant terminant la cause
comment expliquer cela
alors l'explication aujourd'hui qu'on
pourrait qualifier
deux dominantes et une explication de
type matérialiste sociologique qui
consiste à dire ces gens là ont subi une
domination historique ont subi la
colonisation et donc ils ont du mal à
s'identifier aux valeurs du dominant bon
c'est une explication qui est assez
discutable dans la mesure où on peut
constater que toute circonstance égales
toutes les communautés qui ont été
malins serré où historiquement dominé ne
réagissent pas de la même manière
un exemple que j'aime bien prendre dans
ces cas de figure allons aux états unis
et qui verra t-on on y verra des afro
américains qui ont subi l esclavage qui
ont subi un lourd régime de ségrégation
pendant assez longtemps et pourtant le
pasteur martin luther king ne cherchez
pas à subvertir les valeurs américaines
tout au plus déploré est-il que
l'application de ces valeurs étaient
incomplètes
c'est en quoi ils avaient raison et ce
en quoi il aurait encore peut-être
raison aujourd'hui là on est au delà on
est dans le cas de figure d'une
communauté qui ne reconnaît plus
en tout cas le des principes
civilisationnel de base comme la liberté
de croyance et d'expression et je suis
pour ma part convaincu qu'il va falloir
traiter cette question un moment en
confrontant confrontant la théologie
musulmane à ses contradictions parce que
ces raisons là elles sont culturelles
elles sont théologique
on sait que la religion musulmane
entretient avec la liberté de conscience
des relations très conflictuelles
pour des raison très simple c'est que le
coran qui se dit un livre 1 créée qui se
dit la parole de dieu le verbatim de
dieu est un livre qui regorge quand même
de commandement assez violent et
explicites contre les infidèles
c'est un livre qui glorifie l'action n'a
prophète me le prophète mahomet qui dans
sa vie
dans sa biographie est dépeinte comme
quelqu'un qui n'a pas hésité à commander
les actes des assassinats politiques de
ceux qui le moquer de ceux qui le rail
est donc il va falloir s'intéresser à
toutes ces questions théologie si on
veut pouvoir à culture et ceux qui se
réclament aujourd'hui d'islam aux normes
libérales occidentales justement encore
un mot vous qui êtes libéral en quoi ça
vous choque que les étudiants finalement
10 bat chacun doit avoir le droit de
faire ce qu'il veut sinon si je veux
mettre un burqini je mets un burqini
s'il veut venir vous allez à l'école
devient voilée à l'école mais moi je
pense qu'il faut déjà distingué la
question du burck unis et qui sont la
liberté d'expression et de croyance
c'est à dire que moi je considère
effectivement librairie comme un un
costume un peu rétrograde et j'aimerais
qu'on arrive à persuader les musulmans
et les musulmanes que ce
que ce que ce vêtement est rétrograde
maintenant entre ça et la liberté de
conscience le droit à l'apostasié quand
même des enjeux qui sont différents pour
le cas de l'école publique
oui il ya un enjeu on va dire un enjeu
de discipline collective qui consiste à
rester neutre sur le plan religieux mais
vous avez aussi des écoles
confessionnelles privés qui n'ont pas
les mêmes règles donc pour moi l'enjeu
de civilisation n'est pas exactement
similaires moi ce qui m'inquiète
vraiment c'est davantage les questions
de liberté de croyance plus que les
questions de voile et du look ni après
tout si l'islam était une religion qui
entretenait des relations beaucoup plus
amicales avec la liberté de conscience
et d'expression peut-être que le voile
nous nous inquiète rey - donc derrière
le symbole du voile il ya aussi le
symbole d'une religion autoritaire qui
va falloir un moment à prendre a réfuté
sur le plan intellectuel et c'est là où
mon avis il ya urgence à celle millas
vous avez été surprise par les résultats
de ce sondage
non hélas non travaillées arrêtée sur ce
sujet mais je n'ai pas été surpris c'est
dans la continuité d'un certain nombre
d'études je pense à celle de l'institut
montaigne 2016 un également un sondage
de cas publier charlie hebdo juste avant
le procès donc c'est le mot doji tout a
été dit mais il faut sans cesse le il
faut sans cesse le répéter puisque
puisque personne n'écoute mais non alors
moi par contre ce qui m'a un petit peu
plus interpellé alors c'est pas tant le
clivage lycéens musulmans et non
musulmans parce que parce que ça on le
savait il faut vraiment vivre dans une
grotte pour pour pour être surpris mais
c'est que les vous l'avez dit c'est le
premier fait que vous avez cités c'est
que l'essentiel des lycéens 52%
si je me trompe pas sont favorables au
port de signes religieux ostensibles ou
notamment à l'école contre 25% des
français dans les lycées publics dans
les lycées publics sachant que les
musulmans que 14% des lycées en sont
musulmans donc le il ya deux clivages en
réalité qu'il faut noter ya le premier
clivage dont on vient de parler c'est à
dire celui des lycées un musulman et du
reste de la jeunesse et puis il y en a
un autre c'est celui des jeunes et du
reste de la france et celui ci je le
trouve extrêmement inquiétant et on a
tendance à le balayer un petit peu vite
quand je dis on je parle pas là je parle
de manière générale ça ce sont des
jeunes pourquoi pourquoi aujourd'hui il
semble comme ça si peu libéraux bien
moins que leurs parents quelque part
c'est que alors il ya bien sûr l'idée
auch est certain qu'on en ferait
beaucoup trop et qu'on irait discriminer
comme ça les populations musulmanes
alors qu'en réalité quand on regarde de
manière un peu plus concrète la
situation des musulmans en france ne
cesse de s'améliorer le de culte etc
et puis il ya autre chose il ya cette
vision anglo-saxonne qui aujourd'hui
imprègne la jeunesse cette idée qu'on
aurait le droit de ceux obtenus ont des
droits parce que on se sentirait offensé
c'est cette jeunesse qui est qui les
populations
ces français qui sont un peu comme
dirait seront les puceaux de la liberté
qui ne sont pas à l'aise du tout avec la
liberté d'expression le droit de
caricaturer au motif que sa heurterait
et parce que ça heurte on devrait
reculer justement sur un certain nombre
de principes et sur un certain nombre de
droits
et ça je trouve ça extrêmement
inquiétant parce que cette partie de la
jeunesse elle existe ce sont justement
les personnes qui vont qui vont voter
qui vont composer la cité de demain
et là il est difficile de savoir un
petit peu quelques l outil on a il
s'agira pas simplement de tenter de
réformer l'islam et encore je pense que
c'est surtout à l'islam de le faire
lui-même ça va être difficile mais je
dirais plutôt misé savez vous avez vous
avez raison mais en tout cas de lui
permettre de faire comme salek g16
l'interprétation de deux de ses textes
et cette population là elle existe
on la voit peu aujourd'hui heureusement
que cette étude justement mais là
mais l'angle là dessus mais la lumière
sur ce point là ça n'est pas perdue ça
n'est jamais perdue des effets à g c'est
aussi l'opinion de nos internautes
certes 56 % considèrent que le combat
pour la laïcité est déjà perdue chez les
lycéens c'est son c'est la question
qu'on vous a posé sur twitter ça veut
dire voilà qui nous reste encore une
minorité mais quand même importante qui
considère que c'est jouable c'est pas le
cas d'antoine sur youtube qui nous dit
je suis lycéen et je pense que c'est
mort dans le moins assez clair les peurs
sur youtube à nouveau le défi de la
laïcité d'un combat aux lycéens c'est
aux autorités politiques avec les
représentants religieux de se poser sur
de se pencher pardon sur la question il
est bien évident que la laïcité n'est
pas au sens de notre attention quand on
est au lycée
daniel nous dit je pense que les lycéens
c'est à dire ma génération sont plus
enclins à respecter le principe de
laïcité que les générations précédentes
écoutez daniel il faut l'espérer mais
encore une fois c'est pas ce que nous
dit sondages mais ce n'est qu'un sondage
et puis jean louis sur youtube la
laïcité concerne les institutions pas le
peuple fergane asia je suis enclin à
dire oui à ce dernier témoignage et on
peut faire changer les choses ou pas oui
je pense un combat idéologique et
culturelle qu'il faut être prêt à mener
mais encore une fois à condition de bien
les identifier
moi je suis est laïcité aujourd'hui tels
que la france la conçoit si on prend la
définition française de la laïcité il
n'y a que la france est un pays laïc en
europe c'est à dire que les autres pays
ne s'interdisent pas parfois de
subventionner les cultes de on peut le
regretter moi même je le regrette
simplement je pense que la question elle
va au delà c'est un enjeu de
civilisation qui va au delà de la
définition de la neutralité politique de
l'état puisque dans un pays laïque vous
pouvez très bien avoir une société
civile intolérante parce que animé par
des idéologies des cultures des
religions intolérante
donc attention à ne pas réduire c'est ce
combat là là à la question de la laïcité
il faut intégrer c'est un combat
situationnelle beaucoup plus profond et
que je lui dis l'enjeu
c'est non seulement effectivement de
réfuter la théologie musulmane pour la
mettre devant ses contradictions
afin d'inciter ceux qui aujourd'hui se
réclament de l'islam adhérer à des
normes plus libérale mais c'est aussi
rachel a dit tout à l'heure
convaincre aussi réa culture et les non
musulmans
en fait à la liberté de critiquer la
liberté de croyance et là où je serai un
peu tout à fait est là où je serai un
peu plus un peu moins sévère avec vous
sur le modèle anglo saxon parce que je
ne pense pas que le problème il soit
anglo saxons les etats unis ont eu alors
c'était plus le cas aujourd'hui mais
pendant longtemps ont une conception de
la liberté expression beaucoup plus
absolutiste que nous en réalité toutes
ces théories qui consiste à dire que
critiquer la religion d'autrui
cette nuit forme d'impérialisme sont des
gens de bien de chez nous qu'ils ont
théorisé c'est les écoles post moderne
ce sont les michel foucault ce sont les
douars saïd qui est inspiré par un ver
gens que je viens d'une verge ans entre
cet héritage 68 il ya une convergence
quand même et entre cette tyrannie des
minorités qui nous vient quand même tout
droit des états unis qu'on compense les
statuts des volumes logiques qu'ils ont
importé de chez nous c'est à dire que
tous les mouvements postmoderne
américains ne cessent d'aduler jacques
derrida et michel foucault pour leur
avoir justement appris que et bien les
gyms les régimes de vérité ne seraient
pas les mêmes selon qu'on serait en
occident et en orient que l'occidental
ne serait pas légitime a interpellé la
culture de l'autre sous peine de
s'adonner à une forme d'impérialisme
mettre nos centres et donc tout ça vient
aussi de l'hexagone cocorico parfois on
exporte des choses assez assez étonnante
et il va aussi falloir se confronter à
ces écoles de pensée si on veut rétablir
la liberté de croyance en lisant ce
sondage je me mettais à la place des
enseignants je me disais mais qu'est ce
que ça doit être dur pour eux il ya eu
ce traumatisme de l'assassinât de deux
semaines elle pâtit et puis là il voit
que notamment enfin en particulier
plutôt chez chez les lycéens musulmans
le les idées qu'ils essaient de de
propager les convictions si ce sont les
leurs sur la liberté d'expression mais
elle retrouve quand même peu d'écho
c'est des obstacles ils ont rencontré
déjà au lendemain de la tempête charlie
hebdo quand il a fallu justement parlé
de ça un certain non
nombre d'étudiants de jeunes de lycéens
n'ont par exemple pas voulu de la minute
de silence et c'est certain aujourd'hui
alors en saas et des retours qu'on a du
terrain ont compris certains jeunes vont
dire par exemple à d'autres jeunes ça on
le dit entre nous mais surtout ne le dit
pas trop fort il faudrait pas que les
enseignants l'entendre il faudrait pas
que le prof l'entendre parce qu'on ne
peut pas le dire donc il ya maintenant
un nouvel un nouvel enjeu c'est celui
celui du silence on sait à qui on peut
parler à qui on ne le peut pas c'est
très compliqué et là je crois que là
toute une partie de la hiérarchie au 6e
ce sens se sent quelque peu perdus
oubliés abandonnés
et puis le problème vient en partie pas
totalement mais également des
enseignants parce qu' un certain nombre
de ces jeunes là bas forcément
grandissent et se retrouve aujourd'hui à
enseigner donc le problème ne vient pas
toujours des étudiants mais également
des professeurs ça c'est un sujet encore
un petit peu délicat un petit peu tabou
mais c'est quelque chose qui petit à
petit va certainement comme sa marque et
un petit peu plus l'éducation nationale
merci beaucoup à tous les deux j'associe
à mes revers ciment ceux des internautes
ceux de babineau qui nous dit bonne
année bonne analyse de rachel been à
celle d'axel qui nous dit faga nasillard
ya de bonnes remarques bref vous avez
passionner nos internautes merci et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis ce
sera une joie de vous retrouver lundi
prochain
bon week-end
[Musique]